ce que vous auriez dû faire avant de
venir
[Rires]
vous avez invité Gainsbourg on l'entend
pas marqué ça ça prouvait d'abord qu'on
aime vous entendre
ensuite il est pas rasé il est pas net
il a pas de cravate
et bien écoutez j'ai pensé que puisque
nous étions à une époque où on
pratiquait la religion de la de la
performance et que la semaine passée
c'était le Gala de l'Union vous pouviez
faire vous aussi ce qui constituera à la
fois une BA et une performance bon je
veux dire que vous n'y perdrez rien vous
êtes montré tel que vous êtes
habituellement mais pour vous présenter
devant le public ce soir vous allez
m'accorder cette grâce de faire un petit
effort
d'apparaître d'apparaître rasé
d'apparaître bien habillé c'est une
coquetterie élémentaire que les oreilles
non alors écoutez toute façon pour un
musicien il me semble que c'est pas
mauvais d'avoir des dans le vent d'être
un petit peu plus développé de ce côté
là mais accepter mon invitation et je
suis sûr que vous allez conquérir une
nouvelle partie du public vous êtes
d'accord et vous apporter les
les accessoires
[Applaudissements]
ce que vous auriez dû faire avant de
venir
j'ai compris vous allez vous raser je
vais même vous tenir la glace pour vous
montrer que je suis coopératif je
connais pas tout ça oui
nous n'avons pas l'électricité alors je
suis borné à vous donner un instrument
mécanique ok vous voulez que je vous
raconte une histoire oui bien sûr
bien le roi Georges 5 ou 6
qui a dîné un jour avec un paysan je
veux pas être blessé
et il a remarqué je veux dire c'était
avant avant j'ai de carte qui va chez
tout le monde
c'était un paysan
je peux me servir de te faire
[Musique]
ses petits
doigts avec un couteau
le roi a mangé ses petits pots avec un
couteau
[Musique]
et pas forcément rasé
lui en smoke
c'est une fête de vous recevoir et une
fête c'est plus habillée
vous allez voir je suis sûr vous allez
être beaucoup mieux bon bien sûr vos
admirateurs vont pas vous reconnaître
pendant un quart d'heure mais quand même
on va vous arranger vous savez ce qui
vous manque c'est d'être le lendemain
ça y est je crois que je me suis donné
pas de bonnes raisons de nous à rien
n'est-ce pas
à ça tout le monde fait des choses
extraordinaires sans lendemain parce que
je vous fais confiance j'ai pas de bleu
pendant si vous avez une doublure je
vous la présenterai tout à l'heure
pendant 15 jours n'allait pas vous raser
pour
récupérer cet instant pour une autre
chose
comme personne n'y a inventé l'eau tiède
vous aurez de l'eau froide voilà
et je vous signale
ici c'est que je n'ai je ne suis pas mal
rasé
j'ai une barre de naissance
je sais que si vous voulez que vous
allez faire une apparition publique vous
ne vous rasez pas dans les trois jours
qui précèdent
exactement
on pourrait maintenant peut-être
solliciter la vie de quelqu'un qui vous
voit rarement ainsi venez jeune venez me
dire un peu ce que ce que vous en pensez
[Applaudissements]
il est moins propre moins soigné vous
les aimez comme ça oui
la métamorphose on pourrait par exemple
puisque aujourd'hui tout est possible
vous offrir une veste de smoking
peut-être même une cravate
voilà bon vous savez vous êtes déjà un
peu âgé pour le côté blouson noir ou
blouson bleu ça vous dira pas mal ça
fait compositeur arriver
la cravate aussi
fait mieux voilà
il est plus jeune plus non
j'avais pas pensé mais peut-être en
principe ça vous fait plaisir non vous
aviez quand même un peu le snobisme de
la crasse faut appeler les choses par
leurs mains non non
et vous vous n'êtes pas seul on en fera
la déduction qu'on veut c'est ça bon
alors essayons d'en savoir davantage sur
vous deux sur vos débuts encore que pour
jeunes les débuts ça se situe hier on
m'a dit enfin vos biographes affirment
que le dentifrice a tenu dans votre
existence un rôle plus important que
dans d'autres bah oui enfin pas
tellement important parce que rien fait
parce que quand j'étais en école on
était en art on m'a dit que si je
mettais du dentifrice sur mes machins ça
les fait pousser
bah c'est pas vrai tu as vu enfin j'ai
essayé ça mais peut-être ben non mais
peut-être c'était pas le bon Marc parce
qu'il avait une meilleure louche dedans
je me faisais gronder ouais bon alors
ensuite dieu merci et avec le physique
agréable que vous avez nonobstance
surtout le gauche oui en fait si vous
voulez on ne fera pas le détail avec ça
il faut faire du détail c'est pas la
peine de faire en gros
[Musique]